ma mission c'est d'écouter et de voir si
derrière ça parce qu'il faut quand même
le dire depuis quand même maintenant
plus de 28 ans et 30 ans nous savons
nous avons derrière nous des critères de
dangerosité puisqu'on a eu un rapport en
france 1995 où on parlait justement de
définir un mouvement sectaire et c'est
vrai qu'en disait secte ne peut rien
dire par cette définition est au
contraire ce rapport de 81 quasi et bien
il ya en effet des critères de
dangerosité
quand quelqu'un est une déstabilisation
mentale quand quelqu'un entre dans un
mouvement à caractère sectaire
je n'emploie pas le mot secte et il a un
processus
donc le processus de je dirais
d'adhésion de conditionnement de rupture
familiale de contractualisation pour le
groupe tout en laissant tomber
je dirais tout ses centres d'intérêts ça
c'est la mission pour moi en tout cas
c'est ça une emprise sectaire et c'est
comme ça que je la lis mais avec la
famille et la famille est perdue parce
qu'elles ne parlent plus le même langage
elle fréquente un groupe alors religieux
par religieux moi j'en ai rien à faire
mais tout ce que j'ai c'est que en règle
générale il ya toujours de la croyance
et de la doctrine une idéologie en effet
qui peut pour certains et peut-être les
sociologues que j'ai devant moi
et bien c'est une idéologie tout ce que
vous voulez
moi je ne vais pas aller chercher
mouvements à caractère sectaire
on vient chez nous nous en parler j'ai
aucun mérite vous voyez
[Musique]